the aid camp that we were in this
morning you can do the math and figure
out how many more do you need aid from
president erdogram and his government
you can see he's embracing um
a lady that has struggled as a result of
this earthquake measuring 7.8 on the
Richter Scale one of the biggest
earthquakes ever seen here in
Southeastern turkey
the latest death toll is 21
000 people and is expected that that
figure will continue to rise
1999 was the previous
biggest death toll here in Southeastern
turkey when 17 000 people forgive me 17
000 people lost their lives there
put his hand on his heart as you can see
the president offering Solace to those
that
have lost their loved ones she did
I'll come in my Nathan in a pretty good
position to see what's going on here as
I was saying this is totally totally
unpredicted we were here this morning
and there was a lot of questions about
Aid reaching this part